BRAD ORTEGA: What
we're doing today
is trying to make a menu
that you might see in 2050.
The team came up
with three things
that we think we can
squash into the time frame
that we think everybody
is going to enjoy.
The first thing we
addressed is livestock.
And we have three examples
here that we're going
to cook for everybody to taste.
The first one, this is a
regular grain-fed beef.
The next thing is our
department's hamburger.
This is a crafted,
blended burger.
The beauty of this
is it's 30% mushroom.
So we're using all that much
less water, all that much less
grain to feed the product.
The third product we
have is very interesting.
This is an Impossible burger.
It was designed in a lab.
The great thing
about this burger
is it has a 0% cow in it.
I think it's mostly potato
protein, soy protein.
It looks like a hamburger.
It feels like one.
You get the smell.
You get the sizzle.
It's a very, very cool product.
The other thing we
came up with, seaweed.
It's nutrient dense.
No land to grow it.
You don't need any pesticides.
No fertilizer.
It works as a side.
It works mixed with
other vegetables.
I think we hit all
the marks with this.
And the third item we're going
to pull out, it's crickets.
Uses very little land.
Very little water.
Seems to be a pretty sustainable
item loaded with protein,
loaded with calcium.
I took some of this flour
and made a real basic brownie
recipe.
A couple of them have some
whole crickets in them.
A couple of them just
are made with the powder.
I felt if I made
these brownies, I'd
get a lot more takers today.
And the cricket
itself is very bland.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SUBJECT 1: It's good.
SUBJECT 2: It is good.
It's like nuts.
SMITHA HANEEF: Princeton
is about generating
pure knowledge and new
knowledge in the context of now
and into the future.
And through the courses
that are being offered,
students are exposed
enough to make decisions
for themselves and
in the societies
that they will be contributing
to in the next decade or two
decades.
NICOLE KALHORN:
And I was kind of
excited to try the
Impossible burger because I
heard a lot of hype about it.
It's definitely
different texture wise.
But it was kind of cool that
it actually did taste like meat
and it was so juicy.
Still a little bit of
intimidation from bugs.
But I think if I
got more used to it,
or if I didn't actually see
the bug that I was eating
like in the cricket
flour, then it
was a lot easier
to eat the brownie
that didn't have like a cricket
head sticking out of it.
I think it's
definitely a huge step.
It's a really creative
step too actually.
And I think that's
sort of what we need.
I don't think we need
necessarily more crazy,
super-niche technologies.
But it could just be
people trying new things
and being willing
to take more risks
and push past the concept
of eating a cricket.